if you weren't able to purchase rocket
leaks collector's edition the four new
cars that came with it are out now
you can buy these cars individually for
$2 each
but maybe you don't want to buy them all
no problem let's go through each car and
find out which one of these hot rods is
right for you we'll be taking a look at
not just cosmetics but how they handle
in comparison to other cars first up we
got the expert this moon rover buggy
looks similar to the Scarab only it's
way hotter the Esper doesn't just stand
out with Neo Tokyo lights when it hits
max speed this baby transform is opening
up its top it's the only one of the four
that has a hot animation each car has
its own rims and baby you're going to
want to keep these you got a handful of
original paint jobs including mouse cat
or shank as far as performance you could
say the Esper turned similar to the
Scarab and has a hitbox the same as
hotshot just a tad smaller the Marauder
is the biggest of the lot and it feels
the heaviest visually you get a bunch of
original decals like the big buck or
Safari so throw one of these on and go
hunting
car is its hitbox your fan of the octane
it's just a tad bigger and handles
roughly the same the Masamune is
probably the most Tron of them all it
looks a lot like the Takumi only more
slick and smooth you got its own Tron
wheels and original decals like DJ sushi
and road rage look great in general
Masamune feels light on its feet and
with the hitbox similar to the fan faves
Dominus and breakout and then there's
aftershock whole mama if you're an
aerial maniac consider this jet looking
whip and it doesn't just look like a jet
it straight-up sounds like one so
consider flamethrower or nitrous to
really phim this jet engine another plus
with the aftershock is its rocking its
own variation of spinners and it's got
some unique decals get nuclear with Mr
IV and rubble with seismic or he'll put
on the classic wings looks meant to be
and as far as feel it has the exact same
hitbox as Dominus and as a Dominus fan
daddy likey
well there you have it all four new cars
for rocket League due notes performance
findings have been known to change over
time through patches but are generally
to mine or to have any impact that's all
for me thanks for watching
you